and so we come to the end of another
academic year at Yale classes are almost
over exams are almost over on tuesday we
face that strange time of transition
where the tasks of daily life change for
many of us where that routine that set
up a set our life in order changes for
students the end of the semester often
means returning to that ambiguous place
called home that is still home but not
quite home anymore for others of us are
often our summer journeys mean visiting
with those with whom we were once close
family or friends people we once spent
great deal of time with but no longer in
contrast to the immediacy of daily life
at Yale these travels ask longer-term
questions of identity and belonging I
don't know about you but as I meet old
friends after having been apart for a
year or many years I find there is that
often awkward period when we tentatively
asked ourselves in our heads is this
still the same person that I was friends
with does he or she still care about me
or do they just care about the person
that I was then and their memories do I
have anything in common with this person
anymore even people in our own families
after some gentle probing there's
usually one moment in the interaction
where we find a shared memory that
speaks to both of us some experience
that we shared or a time in our lives
that brings us back together a truth
about one another that still applies or
best of all laughter about how clueless
we once were I think that draws me
together best with old friends and
suddenly the months or the years past
fall away and we can reclaim connection
with one another I think this is a taste
of what st. John meant when he had Jesus
say abide in me as i abide in you
rediscovering a connection what I want
to know from my old friend is that some
part of me still abides in them after
all these years not the me of two or
twenty years ago not some ideal picture
of who I was but me or some part of me
the essence of me abiding in their heart
waiting to be rediscovered st. john's
gospel is the mystical gospel of the for
full of meditations on jesus as bread or
water or light or life and in today's
Gospel the image of the vine and the
branches is poetic it's not literal it
wants in a hundred ways to say over and
over again we are like each of us the
tendrils of a vine each reaching out in
our own direction but ultimately rooted
in the vine and the soil itself in God
in His perhaps obscure or poetic way
john wants us to remember we are
connected to Christ and to the God he
calls father and so in this season of
goodbyes and greetings at our church
seems like connection is a good issue
for us to think about as we separate how
are we still connected as new people
come how do they become part of our
community for those leaving it's
questions like will I ever find another
Church like this one or do I even want
to will people here at Yale still
remember me after I'm gone and for those
staying what will happen after all these
people i know have left and we get a new
associate pastor and new people will I
still recognize this place as human
beings no matter how fiercely
independent or ironically distant or
cool we are I think we all yearn in some
way to be known to be accepted to be
connected in a huge chunk of the middle
of st. John's Gospel that we're reading
from today Jesus is trying to prepare
his friends and his disciples for his
coming debt death and resurrection in
these recurring and repeating metaphors
Jesus tries to say
though you will not see me we will still
be connected don't worry about in me as
i abide in you Jesus's ministry his
whole ministry has been devoted to
assuring those that have been told by
the world that they are not worthy of
God or that they are rejected by God
even that they are accepted and loved
over and over again he says it Jesus
finds a hundred ways to say yes you you
you are the one God loves you are the
lost coin you are the lost sheep you are
the prodigal child and Jesus goes on a
step further and John and says not only
are you loved by God you are connected
directly to God God abides in you as you
abide in God you are interwoven with God
like the English ivy on the walls of
battelle chapel but st. John's Jesus
would not have spent so many chapters
imagining one image after another about
connection if that connection were easy
John says it so often because it's hard
for so many reasons we can feel
disconnected from God first perhaps
because the world we live in god bless
it is so secular and scientific and
materialistic and so denuded of spirit
that it completely misunderstands God in
the wonderful new play that's playing at
their rep right now called the realistic
joneses there's a wonderful scene where
Parker Posey who plays a young woman in
there is trying to pray that she knows
nothing about praying she knows
something's wrong with her husband and
she wants to pray but she doesn't know
quite what to do so sitting alone on the
stage she says to god this feels weird
no offense you probably just think I'm
one of so many people you're probably
like my god what does this even about
maybe you're going to burn everything
down anyway I don't know you're crazy
mind you're going to burn everything
down
many of those around us have the
weirdest ideas about who or what God is
and your heart aches for them at those
critical moments when they need to abide
in something but have nothing to abide
him but we ourselves live lives that do
little or nothing each day to remind us
that we are connected to each other or
to God it's hard to do world doesn't
make it easy but we also struggle with
connection with God because we hunger
for personal independence and identity
we want to be ourselves and we want to
do it by ourselves Nadia bolz-weber in
her blog writes that the vines from st.
John are all tangled and messy and how
she doesn't like that much she suggests
that we would much prefer if Jesus used
a different plant image she says Jesus
can I be something a little more
distinct than a vine perhaps a big
bright audacious sunflower that's me she
says Christian life is looks like a
Viney branchy jumbled mess of us and
Jesus and other people and that this is
offensive to Western individualism and
the spiritual consumer culture of today
we live in a world that upholds the
false promise of self-realization it
says you can stave off the insult of sin
or even aging with the right combination
of yoga and self-care and a gluten-free
diet I love her we believe our self if
somehow freed from the clinging vines of
others needs and expectations will save
us but we discover in freedom the
freedom to be alone in our
disappointments that's the end result
never has Christianity beni's
countercultural as it is today because
Jesus says we can only bear fruit if we
turn our backs to the all powerful and
all giving self and are interwoven into
this messy tangle of self and others and
God
is Christ it binds us to needy strangers
and asks us to to question our
unquestionable need for more st. John's
Jesus asked us to look beyond our
individual and social problems of this
annoying moment the relentless worry
about measuring up why did she look at
me that way why do I feel so bad today
why do I do these stupid things why
can't I get my paper written as father
John Shea has written st. John's Jesus
bids us look back to the first chapter
of John's Gospel in the beginning was
the word and the Word was with God and
the Word was God and all things came
into being through this one all things
me you all creation we are connected not
by Disney's circle of life and death but
by the Word of God that abides in us in
the true paradox of faith we can only
gain independence from our problems when
we embrace connection to other people
into God genuine freedom and agency come
not by shedding connections but by
gaining a vision that encompasses and
embraces them when we see the whole
creation suffused with the word then our
motivations and our priorities change in
st. God's language it in st. John's
language God removes every branch in me
that bears no fruit every branch that
bears fruit he prunes to make it bear
more fruit it's a horrible image I had
this vision of God as something out of a
horror movie with a giant pair of
gardening shears coming after me to
prune but it's not a violent process
that God that john wants to describe
it's a process of letting go of the
things that restrict our growth to
finally get tired of the adolescent
willfulness that says i'll show you how
hurt me
as our connection to God grows it crowds
out those self-destructive and obsessive
thoughts it crowds out every envy and
self hatred and fear and in their places
left at first and emptiness scary
emptiness but that emptiness turns into
openness and receptivity to seeing for
the first time how deeply i abide in you
and you and me and all of us in christ
and then we begin to bear fruit in our
passage from first John today not John
but first John the Epistle rider tries
to elaborate on John's Gospel on that
mystical theology and riffs on the word
love as John did on vines or bread or
water finally stating it so boldly that
he says god is love David Bartlett has
written that for the Epistle this
affirmation is not a simple equation god
is love but love is not God love is an
abstraction and the quality of God's own
self love is persona his personification
but God is person love is something but
God does things God sends a Sun God
forgives the sins of the world God gives
commands what the author of first John
is most worried about is that Christians
will think that faith is about
abstractions about truth and love and
things like that without attending to
the specificity of the Crucified one who
was and is both loving and true who acts
in our lives as mostly liberal
Christians if I can generalize we're
tempted to run away from religious rules
or a personal God and dive towards
values or ethics ethics lets us reach
out to a secular world and find our
place without that messy specificity if
we are good people they don't need to
think about God right because God is
love right but the vine and the branches
one tells us finally grow out of one
root and without connection to that
route we cannot grow in my backyard in
Pennsylvania I had trumpet vines that
would take over once a year completely
take over the wall the yard the house
the house next door they grew everywhere
up the walls over the fences ranching
over a 4-foot gap from the wall to the
roof and everywhere luxuriant foliage
and these big bright orange flowers and
I would cut them back and cut them back
trying to rescue the house and the other
plants in the yard but the only way to
battle them I finally discovered it's
not to clip each branch but to trace all
the branches back under the foliage
almost under the ground along the wall
and finally that big gnarled trunk and
take my hacksaw and saw it through our
lives our loves our actions may be
luxuriant and full but only if they're
rooted in the vine and if we are cut off
no matter how huge the branches or
bright the flowers in a day they will
wither and fall abstract love or
goodness is easier than struggling with
the irrational elements and ugly history
of the Christian story but abstract
goodness is rooted in the air in
sentiment and momentary utility and is
swept away in a moment we are called to
abide in and struggle with Christ as we
do with those closest to us staying
connected to God it's not easy these
days but every day that we embrace that
connection is a day of growth and
flowering a day when we know we are
truly known and truly loved by God who
has loved us enough to become one of us
whenever I hear the word abide of course
I think of the hymn which says abide
with me
fast Falls the Eventide the darkness
deepens Lord with me abide when other
helpers fail and comforts flee help of
the helpless Oh abide with me